thank probably what we want to try and
say is this this is probably probably no
it's not quite doing it whatever you
what if we try this yeah this let's
let's try this I think that was oh yeah
yeah all right looks like people maybe
understood that a little bit better but
it's like more importantly what we're
actually trying to say is this so thank
you again nico welcome to our talk on
developing apps that are more accessible
and inclusive for all users and my name
is Maxine and I am Brandon Baris and
both max and I sit on the Google
business development team in New York
and as Nico mentioned we were lucky
enough to steal max away from the Berlin
team to New York but I know he's very
excited to be back here today presenting
to this crowd whoo
go Berlin so let's have a very quick
show of hands who have you here were
easily able to read the slides and able
to understand what we were signing just
now okay well it it's not a ton of hands
up there should we quickly say what we
were doing sure so I was saying hats
late very common and I was attempting to
sign good afternoon and here at Google
we believe that we just wanted to give
you guys a small glimpse or small taste
of what it might have been like to have
an inaccessible experience an experience
that wasn't designed with your needs and
minds and here at Google we believe that
everybody should be able to have an
accessible experience especially when it
comes to your favorite apps and games so
let's start by defining what do we mean
here at Google when we say accessibility
accessibility Refaat refers to the
designs of products devices services or
environments that works to include
everybody
and what you'll hopefully see is that
we've tried to bring the principles of
this statement into our deck today
so you're gonna see things like clear
and simple slides to convey our
messaging high color contrast for the
optimal visual experience we're gonna do
our very best to try and talk and pay
slowly so that could be sometimes a
problem from people who live in New York
so bear with us and according to the
World Health Organization about 15% of
the world lives with some sort of
disability it's over 1 billion people
over 1 billion people who require some
sort of accessibility need to live their
everyday lives
and accessibility needs may be caused by
disabilities that are temporary or
situational such as being deaf or hard
of hearing having some sort of motor
impairment having some sort of cognitive
disability that might impede learning or
blindness and visual impairments and I
think it's probably safe to say that
most folks in this room had we have
either been directly or indirectly
impacted by one of these categories I
know both Max and I have personally been
which is why we're excited to be here
talking to you guys today we wanted to
take a moment just to zoom in on one of
those categories a category that's
probably most relevant for the folks in
this room if you're creating touch app
experiences and that's looking at the
over 250 million people who live with
some sort of visual impairment on a
daily basis and we really just wanted to
give you a little more context to the
size of the user base to the size of
that audience and if you look at that
number that numbers larger than the
country of Brazil it would be the fifth
largest country behind Indonesia in the
United States and that number doesn't
even take into account the additional
342 million people that live with some
sort of color blindness every day and
created an app experience that is that's
accessible for your users not only helps
folks with disabilities but think of a
time in your life or maybe you've had an
accessible experience either with your
favorite app or game or just with life
in general and beyond disabilities
accessibility can be very situational
think of a time where maybe you've been
in a crowded restaurant you're trying to
hear audio or conversation or maybe
you're in a low lighting
situation and you haven't been able to
see your phone or app or anything in the
way you want it to or think of a time or
you've just been frustrated in any
situation maybe you're holding a baby
maybe you're holding a bag of groceries
maybe you're holding anything and you
haven't been able to interact with
something the way that you want to or
the way you expect to to be very
frustrating and when we talk to our
developer ecosystem we often hear that
accessibility is top of mind and
something that they're looking at
prioritize but we found a much different
and frankly a little scarier result when
we ran our quarterly developer
satisfaction survey and during that
survey we asked our developer ecosystem
how they were approaching accessibility
and more importantly how they were
approaching accessibility use cases and
how they were testing for them and what
we found is that nearly 80% of the
ecosystems who responded said that they
don't accommodate for accessibility at
all obviously that's something that both
max and I want to change both by
bringing more awareness to the topic the
importance of the topic as well as
outlining all the great tools and
resources that use developers can start
to take advantage of to create more
accessible and inclusive experiences and
the good news is is that we're here to
help and so I wanted to walk you guys
through the three sections that we're
going to touch on today and the first
one is really that accessibility is is
built into Google's core DNA and so max
is going to take some time to walk you
through all the great work that our
Android team has done to bring
accessibility directly into the platform
I'm thinking I'm then going to take some
time to walk you through the different
tools and resources you have your
fingertips that you can start to take
advantage of immediately to make a more
accessible app experience and then we're
both going to talk to you a little more
about the proactive approach we at play
when I take throughout the rest of 2018
and into 2019 to ensure that
accessibility is being prioritized and
it's top of mind for the ecosystem and
with that I'm gonna hand it over to max
cheers Brandon at Google one of our
guiding philosophies is to organize the
world's information and make it
universally accessible and useful
well the Android team has really taken
the accessible part to heart so I'm
gonna walk you through just a
a few of the examples that make Android
more accessible first off out of the 250
million users with people in the world
with visual impairments 36 million are
legally blind these users can use
technologies such as screen readers or
Braille displays to access their Android
devices because of these technologies
this is how a blind user might dim their
screen to increase their privacy but
retain full usability of their phone
talkback which is Google screen reader
will add spoken and haptic feedback to
your device to make it usable without
ever looking at the screen in the next
section Brandon will talk a little bit
about what you can do to make your app
work really well with screen readers
select to speak helps the over 200
million people who have mid to severe
vision impairments so what you can do if
you have talkback if you have select to
speak enabled you touch your screen and
the phone reads back to you or describes
what you have touched as it turns out
select to speak is also super useful for
people who have difficulty processing
written or visual information or who
have learning disabilities many Android
users suffer from motor disome
disabilities or motor impairments so
this can range from partial to total
paralysis limited dexterity and the
hands or fingers as well as limited
mobility
there are various technologies that help
these users interact with their devices
such as keyboard access or voice control
or head tracking or eye tracking another
technology is switch access so a switch
it's very simple it's basically a big
button that you can press with your hand
or with your head and you can fully
control your device finally I'm going to
talk a little bit about the Android
accessibility menu which is which was
announced at i/o so this is designed
also with people in mind that have motor
design motif impairments so it allows
you with a shortcut on the home screen
or on any screen it allows you to
quickly access functions like starting
the Google assistant opening the app
switcher viewing your notifications as
well as taking screenshots now I know
some of you might know this example but
I think it's super powerful so what I'd
like you to do is take out your phone's
I'm sure all of you have phones and you
said it's very very simple don't be
scared so what I'd like you to do is to
take a screenshot so taking a screenshot
is that work
fairly easy when you're on stage so now
try to doing the same but using only
your weaker hand okay so I'm gonna try
it probably gonna fail so it's it's
quite difficult okay wouldn't it be nice
if there was some sort of easy easy menu
to do it and launch it so having a
disability or some sort of accessibility
need can be super super difficult to
make using your phone super super
difficult so adding little tweaks to
your application or to your to your
operating system can make a huge
difference
for a more complete overview of all the
Android accessibility features I'd love
you to go visit this go link or this
short link here which will take you to a
video recording of the accessibility
session at this year's i/o and it gives
you a great overview of all the
accessibility features built into
Android and all the cool features we're
adding and launching in the
not-too-distant future so Brandon will
now come up and walk you through all the
tools and resources that play and Google
has created to help you make your apps
more accessible Thank You max all right
so let's talk about what you is Android
developers can do to ensure that you're
taking advantage of all the great
features that Macs just walk through as
well as what play is doing to help
invest this group ensure you're meeting
this needs
meeting the needs of this enormous user
groups so by show of hands how many
folks in the audience have heard of the
Android accessibility guidelines all
right so that's about right so we
launched the guidelines a few years ago
as a place where app developers can
access resources to help make their apps
more accessible and inclusive and what
we found when we ran that same developer
satisfaction survey is that nearly 30
percent of developers told us they never
even heard of the guidelines and only
five percent said they knew them well so
again that's something that we want to
change today and so as we look at the
Android accessibility guidelines it's an
area that provides documentation
developer resources and sample code as
developers look to either implement or
improve accessibility in their apps and
the great part about this this resource
is it not only has the broader
documentation but it also has a number
of best practices things like ensuring
that you're labeling your UI elements
correctly to work with so that your app
works with things like screen readers
making sure that you have large large
touch targets so that folks with motor
impairments or like me have fumbly
fingers can easily navigate your app and
ensuring that you're providing proper
color contrast so the users with low
vision who might be using their their
Green's dims can have the optimal
viewing experience and I think the
important part to note here is that a
lot of these updates don't necessary
structuring or heavy dev resources
rather it's taking a moment to think
through the subtle details of how users
are interacting and using your app and
ensuring that you're providing them with
that experience and here at Google is I
hope most folks in this audience know we
have material design material design is
our design language which combines the
principles of good design with science
and technology and within our broader
material design overviews and material
do we also have an entire section
dedicated to accessibility and within
that section we outline how developers
can create really clear robust and
specific experiences so your users can
navigate and utilize the app the way
that they're they want to use it and the
way that it's meant to be used so we'd
encourage you to head over to material
daiya daiya IO and check it out
and probably the most key and important
component within this process to make an
accessible experience is testing your
app currently as we've also published a
getting started guide which outlines the
different methodologies and the ways you
can take go about testing your apps
accessibility and what we found is that
the most accessible apps have really
taken advantage of all three of these
different methodologies to ensure that
nothing is missed when it comes to the
usability and accessibility of your app
and here at Google folks might not be
aware that we also have a first-party
app called the accessibility scanner the
accessibility scanner is available to
download on the Play Store and can be
used with anybody without technical
background you download the app and it
scans the accessibility capabilities on
any app you already have downloaded on
your phone and it helps identify things
like touch target sizes low color
contrast content Lily labeling and more
and when it does is that it gives you
subtle suggestions hot on on how to
improve that or points you to the proper
resources to address it
so again we encourage you to head over
to the Play Store give it a download and
start playing around with it today and
finally as we talked about earlier today
we have the pre-launch reports which
help our developers as they upload their
apks with their app bundles to identify
a number of different usual number of
different issues across a number of
different Android devices before your
app goes public including accessibility
and since launching and accessibility in
the pre-launch reports this past July
we've helped flag over 35 million issues
across 500,000 apps and while this seems
like a fairly large number I think the
thing to point out here is that a lot of
these are very simple fixes things
you're able to fix before you publish
your app publicly and so we again
encourage you to take a look at the
pre-launch reports around accessibility
to ensure you're providing your users
with the most inclusive and accessible
experience when that I'm going to hand
it back to max it's going to talk about
what we're doing throughout the rest of
the year and it's 2019 around
accessibility cheers Brandon some of you
may be wondering well this looks
beneficial but how much work is this
going to be for me or for my team also
how will I be able to prioritize this on
my roadmap well we were thinking exactly
the same earlier this year and we
decided to take a look so I'm going to
walk you through what we've done since
this summer in fact we got together with
a couple of you we we got together with
19 developers from all the global
regions and we did a play accessibility
review pilot and we wanted to do two
things we wanted to understand and learn
how can we review apps for accessibility
at scale and more importantly we wanted
to understand how difficult would it be
for developers to make fixes to make
their app more accessible
and so here are the results here you'll
see the top nine issues that were
discovered during the pilot you can see
the frequency which by which they were
discovered on the egg under y-axis and
the difficulty of fixing them on the
x-axis and I think the key takeaway here
is that a lot of the frequent fixes were
easily fixed but I want to look at the
two most frequent fixes at two most
frequent issues in a little bit more
detail so let's look at an issue that
was seen in almost every single app we
reviewed during the pilot which is
missing or ambiguous ambiguous hints and
labels so imagine you're using your
phone and you're blind or you have
severe vision impairment and you're
using a screen reader and focus on the
search box at the top so the screen
reader would read this as try Beijing
edit box and if you don't have any
visual context as a user you would not
know that this is the way you go to
search for your next destination the fix
for this is actually super super simple
all you would have to do is change the
hint text here and maybe call it
something like search for a place to
visit and immediately users of screen
readers would have a much easier time
navigating your app the really cool
thing here is that this also improves
the usability for any user of your app
not just users of screen readers because
it's clearer what you intend this box to
do by the way we've anonymized all of
these examples because of the sensitive
nature of the accessibility topic so
these are real examples but you won't
recognize the apps now
the second problem which was the second
most frequent during the pilot is that
users of screen readers
we're losing context because of the
focus order with which the screen
readers are going through the apps now
the issue here is that if you're using
linear navigation it may result in your
focus falling on secondary actions like
share or save to favorites before the
focus order comes to the main title or
the the main element of the card and so
as a screen reader user I don't know
what I'm saving to favorites or what I'm
sharing right so that's confusing that's
an issue the fix we classified it I
think as medium to hard is you modify
the focus order and for navigating your
content elements and then you land the
focus lands on the main element first
and then the user can save to favorites
and they'll know why they're doing it so
one thing to think about with Excel
accessibility fixes is how easy is it to
make the app more accessible the other
angle you could take is well what's my
motivation how does accessibility fit
into my company's mission so lift the
ride sharing app the mobile the mobility
app was one of the pilot participants
and we asked them what is your
motivation for participating in this
pilot for investing in accessibility and
the interesting answer that we got is
well our core mission is improving
people's lives through the world's best
transportation and we think that having
a highly successful accessible app is
part of that mission and so they're
using that to justify their investment
and doubling down on making their app
more accessible and I think that's a
really nice story to share so if you're
thinking about this
think about how it fits into your
mission now the accessibility pilot was
a really good experience and a very good
learning experience for both asset play
as well as for the developers that
participated but we realize that this
was just the first step so going forward
we're going to Double Down the first
thing we're doing is we're including
accessibility feedback in all platform
design reviews that play will do for
those of you who don't know a platform
design review is similar but more
extensive than the review we do and when
we feature apps on the store so now you
can ask for this and have your app
reviewed for accessibility and we'll
send you really easy to digest feedback
and suggestions the second thing we're
doing starting in 2019 we're going to
provide further opportunities for highly
accessible apps to be discovered on the
store this may mean that when we make
editorial decisions that we look at how
accessible is this app when we decide to
feature and the other thing that we're
doing is we're investigating how to
surface highly accessible apps in search
and throughout the store
well preparing for this session we met a
bunch of very very amazing and dedicated
people who are working unaccessible it
was inspiring to see their passion as
well as the progress that they've made
so I want to say or we wanted to say a
big thank you all for joining and taking
the time to learn about this very
important topic and if you were not
working on accessibility before or not
prioritizing it we really really hope
that we inspired you to take action and
I would just say if you're getting
started on accessibility please
definitely take advantage of these two
links on the screens there's a great
video on YouTube around what's new and
accessibility on Android and then also
an article that gives an accessibility
overview on developers that we'd highly
suggest taking a look definitely make
sure you reach out to your BD manager
your contact to play for a platform
design review that max mentioned and if
you've already invested an accessibility
please come find us come talk to us we'd
love to hear why you prioritized it any
insights you can provide and partner to
see how we can bring that information
back to the ecosystem and if you walk
away with one thing from the session we
hope that it's not only are you creating
an experience for folks with
disabilities to have an accessible
experience that bringing in these core
functionalities to your app will make it
a better user experience for all users
so we thank you and I don't believe we
have time for questions according to
this screen unless we do but we thank
you
[Applause]